hello you're playing the waiting game
the video game recommendations show this
week were wielding south park the stick
of truth nagasaki it may have been
delayed not to mention filing itself on
the sadly sinking ship that was THQ
before Ubisoft bought it out but
nonetheless south park the stick of
truth is looking pretty good you play as
the newest kid in town going on a series
of quests with the colorful characters
of the comedy central cartoon all of it
bundled up with some surprisingly deep
RPG mechanics but until you get to
Rochambeau children in a Colorado
fantasy world what should you do to stay
entertained let's see or pure-hearted
one will you please come and see if I
would well if you're looking for a
light-hearted game that still packed the
punch of a proper RPG you should take a
look at knee no kuni the beautiful game
from Studio Ghibli tells the story of
Oliver a boy trying to defeat an evil
wizard and bring his mother back to life
as you do while it may look childlike
knee no kuni shouldn't be underestimated
it's a proper JRPG with a host of
characters you can direct in combat
it'll take you quite a while to get
through but if you want an upbeat RPG
you'd be hard-pressed to find better
that said knee no kuni is all a bit safe
it's all flowers and sunshine it's a
little bit kidzee what if you want
something closer to the bite of south
park well you should probably play grim
fandango released back in 1998 grim
fandango is an undisputed classic you
play as Manny calavera a travel agent
for the Department of death in the land
of the dead starting to see why we
picked this one now as for the execution
it's a classic adventure game forcing
you to find the right objects and say
the right thing is to progress
ooh ick it came out like soft-serve ice
cream but judging by the smell I think
it's auto body fuller most of the
writing comes from industry legend Tim
Schafer so you're practically guaranteed
to enjoy yourself which is good really
because Matt Stone and Trey Parker are
doing the writing for south park the
stick of truth and they're pretty funny
too so has anyone seen the Barnett you
all right now South Park is doubtless
you're aware is anything but predictable
over the series 17-year history they've
done just about everything imaginable
and only about twelve percent of it has
been tasteful if you want something
similarly off-the-wall the hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy is an absolute
must-read written by the inimitable
Douglas Adams Hitchhiker's Guide was
originally a radio comedy before being
adapted into a series of novels
concerning themselves with the mysteries
of the universe after the destruction of
Earth the books are hugely culturally
prevalent and chances are if you read
them for the first time you'll spot at
least one thing you'd already
encountered in reference form elsewhere
it may not be a fantasy RPG like the
stick of truth but if what we've seen of
the game so far is anything to go on
it's every bit as unpredictable all
right that's books in games covered off
so we may as well give you something to
watch oh my god you killed a hooker hall
girl she's a zero when they're dead
they're just hookers Archer is a secret
agent working for Isis given he's a
womanizing alcoholic with little regard
for the safety of others and then ego
the size of the western hemisphere he
really should have lost his job by now
good for him then Isis is owned and
operated by his mother Archer has some
wonderfully fast-paced dialogue and
there's not one dull character in the
entire show easily the closest thing on
TV to South Park's own shock value if
you don't watch archer you are seriously
missing out if you do watch archer
you're all right that said while the
antics of sterling Malory Archer are
outlandish they don't quite match South
Park when it comes to sheer
tastelessness yeah
that's a pain but this is the kind of
stuff you put up with living in a remote
little mountain town if you're looking
for something likely to make you spit
your drink out all over the place you
should really watch drawn together oh
sure you're not morbidly obese honey an
alarmingly uncompromising cartoon drawn
together tells the story of a series of
cartoon characters shoved into a house
for a reality TV show taking aim at
everything from disney princesses and
Pokemon to Betty Boop SpongeBob
SquarePants to link it's a seriously
frenetic show that delights in taking no
prisoners okay it may not match the
lofty heights of satire South Park of
Italy reaches but it's still a
delightfully cheeky watch and if you're
a dedicated South Park fan you'll
definitely get something out of it
speaking of getting something out I'm
getting out of here they'll be more
waiting game for you next week but if
you want to check out any of the things
we discussed in this episode follow the
link on screen now for a useful amazon
list and as ever feel free to make your
own recommendations in a comment or by
tweeting with the hashtag GS waiting
game bye for now
you